الأطفال المبتسرين المنفصلين عنهم
حاضنات الإسعاف مع المصابين
هاجم الآلاف من الأشخاص المهجورين
تحت الأنقاض يصرخون طلبا للمساعدة
قتل الآلاف من الناس بوحشية
من قبل دولة إسرائيل الإجرامية كثيرة
منهم الفتيان والفتيات ونحن
حضور الإبادة الجماعية على الهواء مباشرة و
لا أريد أن أكون شريكاً، أريد أن أتصرف.
أريد تعزيز وقف إطلاق النار و
انتهي من هذا
لأن الهمجية إذا لم توقفها
الوقت يسحبك معه اليوم
يمكن للفلسطينيين غدا
كن أي شخص لن نسمح له
الإبادة الجماعية بصمتنا وصمتنا
التواطؤ لهذا السبب قررنا أن نمرر
إلى عمل أكثر من 60 برلمانيا و
برلمانيون من جميع أنحاء أوروبا وأمريكا
لاتينا سوف نأخذ نيتان ياهو و
قيادتها السياسية أمام محكمة الجنايات
دولية ولكننا بحاجة إلى أن نكون أكثر
ادعم هذه المبادرة بتوقيعك
خطوة إلى الأمام رفع
صوت